[موسيقى]
هنا نذهب
لدخول عالم سوبر نينتندو من خلال
أنبوب الاعوجاج اتبعني
[موسيقى]
وها نحن هنا نسخة طبق الأصل بالحجم الطبيعي
لأشهر ألعاب نينتندو ، لديك
قلعة مغامرات يوشي وقلعة بيتش
وجميع الشخصيات الشهيرة
بعد ذلك  ما يقرب من عام تأخير
بسبب kobit 19 ، تم فتح
هذه الحديقة الترفيهية في استوديوهات أوساكا العالمية في
اليابان للجمهور أخيرًا ، وقد حصلنا
على نظرة خاطفة قبل أن
تأتي الحشود الكبيرة ،
ولكن هكذا تبدو الأشياء أثناء احتوائها
على درجة حرارتك.
يوجد معقم يد المدخل في كل مكان
مطلوب أقنعة في جميع الأوقات باستثناء
المناطق الخالية من الكتلة
حتى أتمكن من التفاعل مع ماريو ولويجي
ولكن هناك قواعد ضد
اللمس وأحد الأماكن القليلة في
هذه الحديقة بأكملها حيث يمكنني خلع قناعتي
موجودون في منطقة التقاط الصور هذه
مع ماريو ولويجي وفي الواقع على
الأرض هنا توجد علامات
لإثبات أنني بحاجة إلى أن أكون
بعيدًا عنهم حتى أكون
بعيدًا اجتماعيًا
عن ماريو  يقول مسؤولو luigi park
أن هذا كله كلف حوالي نصف مليار
دولار للبناء وأكثر من
ست سنوات لتطوير صناعة الألعاب الآن
، وحصلت نينتندو بشكل خاص على
دفعة كبيرة أثناء الوباء
حيث كان المزيد من الناس عالقين في المنزل داخل
لعب ألعاب نينتندو
التي  تصبح الحياة الواقعية في هذه الحديقة
، الحديقة بأكملها تفاعلية ، يمكنك
حتى التنافس ضد أشخاص آخرين هنا
، وكما هو الحال في ألعاب فيديو ماريو ،
فقد حصلت على شريط الطاقة هذا على
معصمي ويمكنني فقط الضغط على هذه
الكتل وأنا  احصل على نقاط في تطبيق ماريو على
هاتفي وهذا أكثر ما يثيره العديد من المعجبين
حول تحدي koopa
وهو سباق ماريو كارت الواقعي عبر
قلعة العربة ،
حسنًا ، أنا على وشك الدخول في
لعبة ماريو كارت الحقيقية التي
يجب أن أضعها على  سماعة الواقع المعزز
هنا ، قم
بقصها جيدًا ،
دعنا نذهب إلى سماعة الواقع المعزز التي
اعتدت عليها قليلاً ، لكنني
كنت أتسابق عبر مملكة الفطر
بجوار الأميرة الخوخ ماريو
ولويجي ، لست كذلك  رائع في إصدار لعبة الفيديو
من ماريو كارت ، أعتقد أنني
ربما أكون أفضل قليلاً
في إصدار الحياة الواقعية لـ نينتندو ،
هذه
خطوة مهمة تتجاوز أعمالها
الأساسية في ألعاب الفيديو ووحدات التحكم
التي تستفيد من كنزها الدفين من
الملكية الفكرية والأيقونية
شخصيات
هنا في المتجر وفي مطعم
كانوبيو كافيه نحن هنا في
مملكة الفطر والطعام الذي يحمل طابع الفطر
موجود في كل مكان يبدو كأنه طعام كرتوني
لكنه صالح للأكل
أخبرتني عندما رأيت كل هذا
أنني كنت عاطفيًا كنت ألعب نينتندو
الألعاب منذ أن كنت
صغيرًا ، ليس من المبالغة القول إن ألعاب ماريو
رفعتني ، كل هذا يتجاوز توقعاتي ، لقد أخبرتني أنني أشعر أنني في عالم ماريو ، أشعر بالقلق من kovid عندما
أخلع قناعتي لتناول الطعام قالت ولكن
تتخذ الحديقة بروتوكولات السلامة ، لذلك أشعر
بالأمان
، حدود اليابان لا تزال مغلقة ، لذا
لا يُسمح للمسافرين الدوليين
في هذه الحديقة حتى الآن ، ولكن
هناك خطط لفتح عالم سوبر نينتندو
في حالة عائمة  يقول ريدا كاليفورنيا
ومبتكر ماريو سنغافورة شيغيرو
مياموتو إنه يريد
أن يأتي العالم كله لزيارته عندما ينتهي الوباء
سيلينا وانغ سي إن إن طوكيو